okay so we're going to program a new key
more these for a 2017 GMC Sierra will
also work for a Silverado I know that it
should work for a 2014 - I believe 2018
so if you've got a key like this this is
the GMC I'll put a link where you can
buy these on Amazon for I think they're
like ten dollars you'll have to have it
cut I took it to my local locksmith - to
have it this is a pretty easy procedure
just to show you that this is not a
programmed key I'll put it in you'll see
the I'm gonna turn it to start and
you'll see I've got the immobilizer
symbol so the vehicle will not start
right now you'll see where it says theft
deterrent system so the key is not
programmed so all you do to program
these yourself is you take a programmed
key you can also do this if you have
lost your keys it's a 30-minute
procedure I could possibly do another
video like that if enough people need to
see that most people have at least one
key they just want a spare key so order
one of these for $10 off Amazon and you
can do it yourself
no no scanner required no machine
required no locksmith or dealer required
to do this you can do it yourself so all
you do take your original key put it in
turn it on
to the run position you don't have to
start the vehicle you'll see that the
immobilizer light just went out
turn the key off within five seconds put
the new key on turn it on wait about
five seconds the immobilizer light
should go off turn the key off and that
said start and that's all there is to it
that's the one nice thing about GM
products is they allow you to do this
yourself with no with no problem so
again I'll put a link this is an actual
factory GMC key that you can get off
Amazon it's not a some oddball
aftermarket all you'll have to do it'll
come uncut you'll just need to have a
locksmith or four dealer cut it
locksmiths probably gonna be a little
cheaper and you're gonna be able to do
this yourself anyway that is all I've
got just want to show you how easy that
is to do yourself
take care